de nuit fait appel à un paysagiste pour
embellir la devanture de sa maison
aménagement pierre lafleur mais malheur
plates-bandes pavé de l'entrée chemin en
galets tout le travail a été mal fait
denise décide de poursuivre le
paysagiste à la division des petites
créances mais qui poursuivent
pierre lafleur la personne ou
aménagement pierre lafleur l'entreprise
lorsqu'une entreprise est incorporé par
quelqu'un elle est considérée comme une
autre entité comme une personne
distingue elle à ses obligations et ses
droits et quand cette entreprise
incorporée et son créateur ont presque
le même nom cela peut porter à confusion
dans le cas de denise c'est bel et bien
pierre lafleur qui a mal fait le travail
mais la transaction a été faite avec la
compagnie c'est donc celle ci qu'elle
devra poursuivre le fin mot de
l'histoire
si vous confondez une personne et sa
compagnie vous risquez de vous planter